you know the scientists and the public
are very concerned by the growing
numbers and we've got a government
that's hinting at further restrictions
but it's more concerned and tied up with
party management at the moment than it
is with public health and i think what
we want what the public wants is a prime
minister with a plan and with a grip and
the question on my lips and i think the
public lips this morning is where is the
prime minister and so what are you
calling for a labour calling for well
we've made it clear to the government
that we stand ready to support further
measures if necessary i made that clear
to the prime minister last week i make
it clear again today but it's for the
prime minister to come up with a plan
with support for schools for businesses
etc so the ball's in his court but where
is he and i think this obsession with
party management rather than public
health is the wrong priority at the
wrong time so you'll support new
measures if necessary of what what is
that is that possibilities of a circuit
break lockdown would labor be supportive
of those motions well we'll look at what
the government puts forward but the
government's got to come up with a plan
because whatever the measures are there
needs to be economic support for
businesses etcetera we need to know
there's real clarity that we can get our
schools open
when the new term starts so they're our
priorities um but we say to the
government get on with the job
bring forward that plan we will look at
it and just as we've done throughout the
pandemic just as we did with our votes
last week we will support it if it's the
right plan uh in the public interest
cases are rising we're seeing each
passing day more cases than before um
has has the government been too slow on
this well look throughout the pandemic
my strong feeling is the government has
been too slow but here we are with the
variant that everybody's very very
concerned about and what i want to see
is a government a prime minister that
gets a grip and puts a plan forward that
hopefully we can all get behind but
where is he there's a
vacuum of leadership at the moment the
infighting is going on in the tory party
when the focus should really be on on
the public interest and public health
we've got christmas and new year coming
up so if you were prime minister
what kind of restrictions would you put
in place would you put any in place are
you happy with families meeting in large
groups over christmas well i would be
getting my cabinet together i would be
having a cobra meeting which i would
attend
with all four nations to come up with a
strong plan including the necessary
support now we don't have access to all
the information that the prime minister
and the government have got they've got
that information i think people are
crying out for some leadership here to
say to the prime minister where are you
come up with a plan don't hint that
restrictions come up with a plan let us
see what the support is and we the
opposition say as we've said before if
it's a plan that we think is right and
in the public interest uh we will
support it i've already made that clear
to the prime minister and make it clear
again today so just to be clear
christmas is this week you are content
with the restrictions that are in place
at the moment going into christmas i
want the prime minister to come forward
with his plan with the necessary support
tell us tell the public what it is and
then if we think it's the right plan we
will support it the moment my
frustration and it's the frustration i
think of many many people is the prime
minister completely absent you know not
attending meetings not being out there
hasn't got a grip hasn't got a plan
and you know public health has to come
first not party management
do you have a plan that you say prime
minister doesn't have a plan do labor do
you have a plan well we're very
concerned about the numbers
we have discussed it with the
medical and scientific advisors but of
course we don't have access to all of
the information about what support could
go in so it really is the job of the
government to come up with a plan we the
opposition have said we'll be
responsible not with standing with the
opposition if it is the right plan we
will support it just as we did last week
we wouldn't even have the plan b
restrictions if the labour party hadn't
acted in the public interest i will
continue to act in the public interest
but we do need a prime minister who is
present who has got a grip and got a
plan
just one other question on this
photograph that has come out of both
from downing street of the prime
minister and some staff socializing in
what was reported to be may last year um
what are your thoughts on that well
everybody will have looked at that
photograph um and to suggest that that
is a work meeting
is a bit of a stretch
by anybody's analysis so i think there
are very serious questions to be
answered but just look at the photo
and ask yourself is that a work meeting
going on or is that a social event and i
think the answer is pretty obvious you
didn't have any meetings like that any
of any work meetings or events like that
may last year look i look forward to the
day when i'm meeting uh in the
back garden of downing street but no the
labour party and the vast majority of
the public were complying with the rules
and you know all
joking apart
during that period there were funerals
of people where very few people could go
and mourn those that had
tragically died you know that's that's
the contrast that picture um you know
which as i say is a real stretch to
pretend that that's a work meeting
versus an up against pictures of
of those who have lost someone and not
been able even to go to the funeral